on this thursday night world cup goals
the canadian city is winning their bid
to host the world's biggest soccer event
so much of the visitor economy will
benefit but so will the broader economy
relief aimed at helping canadians with
rising inflation
we will take real and tangible steps
the fed's five step plan worth nine
billion dollars
major change in the air
the service modifications westjet has
waiting in the wings
and need for speed it's going to be a
fantastic weekend tourists race to
montreal for the canadian grand prix's
return
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you so much for
joining us some breaking news to tell
you about this hour two canadian cities
will play host to the most watched
sporting event on the planet fifa has
announced toronto and vancouver as hosts
for the 2026 world cup and they'll be
joining other host cities across north
america for the global event and even
though
many watch parties across the continent
are celebrating
there is one canadian city that was left
out eric sorenson has tonight's top
story
a toronto football club watch party was
not disappointed
toronto one of two canadian cities that
will make history [ __ ] field to stage
world cup games in 2026. unbelievable
man like the world the world cup coming
here and vancouver's bc place will host
matches now kicking off a sport and
tourism boost potentially worth hundreds
of millions of dollars we know all the
eyes of the world will be on vancouver
for those games so much of the visitor
economy will benefit but so will the
broader economy it's the first time fifa
picked three countries to co-host the
world cup in all 22 north american
cities were considered the canadian
venues need upgrades toronto's [ __ ] field
capacity will have to be increased from
30 thousand seats to forty to forty five
thousand to comply with fifa
requirements vancouver's bc place the
artificial turf will have to be replaced
with natural grass capacity is not a
problem but the third candidate edmonton
with its historic commonwealth stadium
was not chosen for the world cup a
disappointment for a city that helped
elevate international soccer in
particular growing the women's game in
this country so obviously
disappointed but
i know we we will continue to explore
opportunities for us to host other
events the u.s will host the most games
in stadiums across the country and in
mexico matches will be held in three
cities when canada joined the u.s and
mexico in a world cup bid more than five
years ago the hope was to grow the sport
in this country and to build a team
worthy of being in the world cup the
remarkable thing is canadian men's
soccer didn't wait for 2026. canada
shocked the soccer world when the team
led by alfonso davies qualified
spectacularly for this year's world cup
suddenly a talented soccer team and the
world cup coming here it will bring so
much more attention from the global
soccer world with canada qualifying for
the 2022 world cup as a great lead up to
2026. the timing couldn't be better
men's soccer coming into its own just as
the country builds world cup fever for
2026. eric sorensen global news toronto
while there's no doubt hosting the world
cup will be a significant expense the
announcement comes at a time of high
inflation and rising interest rates with
no promises from the federal government
about funding the tournament finance
minister christopher freeland did
promise a significant announcement today
on affordability
but what canadians got instead was a
speech detailing measures already
announced in the last two budgets
abigail b minn reports
nicole isn't pleased about steep
increases to the cost of living nor the
bank of canada hiking interest rates to
try and tackle it if you're still in the
hustle and grind like the most of us
interest rates affect everything with
inflation hitting 6.8 percent in april
what to do is on everyone's mind you
think about what you're going to buy
before you go out you know what i'm
buying how much i'm buying and when i'm
buying it it's costing a lot of money
for people that are you know whether
they're a student or maybe low income we
will take real and tangible steps to get
inflation under control
and to make life more affordable in her
first major address since the budget the
finance minister wants to remind
canadians they're working on things
outlining 8.9 billion dollars previously
announced for things like 10 a day child
care a 10 percent increase to old age
security and boosting the canada workers
benefit
some of it has started to arrive
a lot of it is coming in the course of
this year and it's a lot of money
because the only thing this speech will
outline that's going to help them is a
seven dollar increase for some kidneys
that's all they're getting looking
through these flyers there's not a lot
you can buy in a grocery store for an
extra seven dollars the opposition says
funding these programs won't drive down
inflation we don't believe that what
christian freeland has put forward is
going to help with the struggles
canadians are going through right now
one economist tells global news the
promised measures aren't likely to help
because pouring more money into the
economy creates more demand if they work
as intended they wouldn't be creating
excess demand the way that
they did back in 2020 when the
government just inserted a lot of money
in the economy
creating excess demand and that led to
the high inflation we're seeing today
the tricky balancing act is about how to
cool down the economy without getting so
cold as to drive a recession the finance
minister was asked about that in several
ways christopher calling it a volatile
and uncertain economic time largely
driven she says by the global economy
and she won't speculate on what the next
weeks or months may bring
abigail beeman global news ottawa
and here is another example of the
far-reaching impacts of the pandemic and
the ongoing financial uncertainty
westjet is scaling back operations in a
blog post the airline says it will be
concentrating on service within western
canada and to sun destinations and
halting the expansion of its fleet of
dreamliner jets westjet says service to
eastern canada will be scaled back the
airline announced plans back in march to
buy low-cost rival sunwing
in washington the committee
investigating the january 6 attack on
the u.s capitol focused on former vice
president mike pence and former
president donald trump's attempts to
force his vp to overturn the 2020
election
now even though as the committee heard
trump and his advisors knew they were
relying on a baseless legal claim that
pence could actually do that jackson
proskow reports
that mike pence became the target of the
mob on january 6th should have been no
surprise he can decide on the validity
of these crooked ballots after a public
pressure campaign led by former
president trump and his allies that
continued while the capitol was under
attack did donald trump ever call the
vice president to check on his safety
he did not the committee investigating
january 6 revealed the depths of the
efforts to pressure pence all based on
false claims that pence could somehow
stop the certification of joe biden's
victory even as he was whisked away for
his own safety pence never caved his
legal advisers testified that for nearly
a month they backed the vp's gut
instinct that he had no authority to
overturn the election there is no
justifiable basis to conclude that the
vice president has that kind of
authority the committee heard that trump
allied lawyer john eastman pushed the
dubious legal theory though evidence
suggests he never believed it himself
and was repeatedly told to drop it
i said are you out of your f in mind
trump went along with it anyway on the
morning of january 6 witnesses recall a
heated phone call between the president
and his vp i remember hearing the word
wimp either he called him a wimp it was
a different tone than i'd heard him take
with the vice president before a short
time later trump gave that infamous
address from the white house lawn so i
hope mike has the courage to do what he
has to do he continued tweeting about
pence even as the capital was under
attack
of america as trump poured gas on the
fire pence was whisked away
new photos show him waiting in a secure
underground location in the capitol
during the attack at points just 12
meters from the rioters
most remarkable through it all the vp
refused secret service attempts to
evacuate him from the building
make no mistake about the fact that the
vice president's life was in danger
a recent court filing by the department
of justice explains that a confidential
informant from the proud boys told the
fbi the proud boys
would have killed mike pence if given a
chance
just stunning findings coming out of the
hearings today jackson
could this testimony lead to criminal
prosecutions against trump or others
well far the committee certainly hinted
that there is more to come in all of
this today in fact the department of
justice put out a letter requesting
interview transcripts of the 1 000
people interviewed by the committee
saying they're relevant to future and
ongoing criminal prosecutions one other
thing they'll likely be interested in
john eastman that trump-friendly lawyer
we heard today in the committee that he
proactively requested a presidential
pardon in the days immediately following
january 6th
jackson frosco in washington thank you
jackson all right turning now to the war
in ukraine and a powerful show of
support from western european leaders
the trio from france germany and italy
traveled to keefe to meet with president
vladomir zielinski to get a first-hand
look at the destruction as sean o'shea
reports from kiev the leaders are
pledging more support for ukraine's
fight against russia and they are
backing the country's bid to join the
european union
as russia's war on ukraine reached its
112th day
ukraine's plea for help from other
countries got a welcome boost
leaders of three key european countries
took an overnight train to ukraine their
first visit here since the war began
french president emmanuel macron german
chancellor olaf schultz and italian
prime minister mario draghi meeting with
ukraine's leadership and getting a tour
of burpine a half hour west of the
capital the war has started not on the
24th of february the war has started in
2014. this is a city where 70 of all
buildings have been destroyed by russian
shelling
macron telling reporters massacres were
carried out we have the first signs of
war crimes the german chancellor
described what he called the brutality
of the russian war of aggression
the destruction this war is causing he
said is terrible the leaders came here
for more than just a tour though after a
meeting with ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky macron promised to
provide six more caesar long-range guns
to ukraine as a group the leaders all
said they support granting ukraine's
status in the european union immediately
move that could make it easier to get
more support from neighboring countries
soon and a decision on eu status is
right around the corner the eu meets a
week from now to decide whether ukraine
will be accepted possibly with some
conditions and president zielinski has
been invited to attend the g7 summit
which begins june 26th but he won't be
leaving ukraine he'll be joining by
video link pharah
sean shea reporting thank you sean
in their own words coming up a broadcast
exclusive with the two men wrongly
arrested in the parliament hill bomb
scare
two sick rally organizers arrested near
parliament hill saturday after a false
bomb tip are speaking out tonight in a
broadcast exclusive ottawa police say
the rcmp is investigating while there
are growing calls from the sikh
community for answers about what led to
the arrests mercedes stevenson reports
it's a really a dark day of my life i
mean it's totally disturbing totally
destroying my reputation two prominent
sick community organizers targeted in a
terrorism hoax want answers and a police
apology after they were arrested and
detained on a bogus tip claiming they
planned to blow up car bombs near
parliament hill i couldn't sleep
since saturday night you know
it's it's going through in my mind who's
behind this parminder and manvir came to
ottawa for a peaceful annual rally they
organized to commemorate the june 1984
massacre of six in india
it never occurred to either of the men
that the massive police presence they
found on parliament hill was looking for
them after a detailed tip from the
canada border services agency police had
their photographs and license plates
manveer had just finished speaking at
the rally when officers approached him
he said you know that there's explosives
in your car i said no but i just
came from my home
you know i brought my family in the same
car parminder was next we got a threat
under your name
a bomb threat under your name
and i got shocked i mean i say what i
mean i can't believe this both were
arrested handcuffed and taken to the
police station they asked me to remove
my turbine a deeply painful act for a
sick man these are religious signs and
we are connected with them emotionally
but i had no choice because the
allegation was too big
you know they could
they could do anything if i'm not
obeying them you're wasting taxpayer
money what is this nonsense after a
couple of hours police said the two were
victims of a terrorism hoax apologized
and released them i say i know that i'm
not involved in this but
the way it's the situation being handled
is totally wrongfully interim police
chief steve bell defended the force's
response saying the warning came in at
11 a.m giving police little time to
respond
bella said police acted in good faith
and worked as quickly and effectively as
possible
the experience shocked the two canadian
citizens i'm not that kind of person we
love canada both are well known leaders
with extensive political contacts
parmender has worked with conservative
liberal and ndp politicians
manveer has been an outspoken supporter
of an independent kalistan an issue that
has been a flash point in canada-india
relations
manveer says he was supposed to be part
of prime minister trudeau's official
delegation to india in 2018 but wasn't
able to board the pm's plane so he went
on his own dime and was greeted with
controversy over his kalistani
separatist views which he has said have
always been peaceful
regardless of what's behind saturday's
hoax the two men want to know who or
what targeted them fearing it could
happen again farah
mercedes stephenson in ottawa thank you
mercedes
canada's chief justice says the legal
system cannot go back to the way things
were before the pandemic
our justice system must continue
to modernize and to innovate it is our
duty to do so knowing that access to
justice is not just one basic right or
service but first and foremost a basic
human need and as such it is an
essential ingredient of democracy
wagner made the comments during his
annual update on the work of the supreme
court he admits meeting the expectation
of timely justice is a big task with so
many courts facing backlogs but he
believes processes can be improved
the current privacy law in canada was
last updated more than 20 years ago
that was before the advent of technology
such as social media and and smartphones
it is therefore i time to ensure that
canada has a strong a safe and very
flexible regulatory framework which is
adapted to today's technology
that science and innovation minister
francois philippe champagne he's
introducing new federal legislation
today aimed at regulating the way
companies collect and use data in canada
and the use of ai the bill would force
that consent is obtained through plain
language instead of legal jargon ensure
data is secure and allow canadians to
permanently delete information
temperature records scorched ahead tens
of millions of americans simmer under a
dangerous heat wave
over a third of the u.s population is
being urged to stay inside as a
dangerous heat wave settles in more than
100 million americans are under heat
alerts temperatures are soaring across
the midwest southeast and parts of
southern california and arizona more
than a dozen cities are setting
temperature records reaching over 43
degrees in some areas forecasters say it
could take weeks to feel some relief
and an extreme heat event is also
hitting parts of europe temperatures in
spain and france are reaching highs not
normally recorded until mid-summer
forecasters in southern france have
activated a heat alert temperatures are
expected to exceed 40 degrees in some
places by this weekend the hot air mass
is coming in from neighboring spain
where early june temperatures are the
highest registered in the country in the
last 20 years
both countries already recorded the
hottest may on record
after kevin spacey was granted
unconditional bail during his first
appearance at a british court over
charges of sexual assault dating back
almost 20 years
keep moving
keep leaving
spacey was mobbed by the media as he
arrived in london today where he faces
five sexual assault charges involving
three british men and dating back to
2005. the 62 year old was not asked to
enter pleas for the alleged offenses
he's scheduled to be back in court on
july 14th
fast and festive next montr's gear up
for the return of a high-speed
competition
montreal is revving up for the return at
the canadian grand prix after a long
pandemic pause a few places on the
planet embrace formula one quite like
quebecers as dan spector reports the
race is the only canadian stop on the f1
calendar and is by far montreal's
biggest event of the year
the streets of downtown montreal haven't
been this busy since june of 2019 and
that can only mean one thing
the cars are back the tourists are back
and after two consecutive covet
cancellations the formula one canadian
grand prix is finally making its
long-awaited return it's really nice to
see us coming back to a little bit more
of a normal scenario
sure they come for the race but while
they're here visitors drop big money a
tourism industry ravaged by the pandemic
is exploding with excitement don't false
this montreal bar owner says
reservations are pouring in and everyone
wants champagne
it's almost half of our profit of the
years you know we're fully booked it's
97 occupancy in our hotel same thing in
terms of the uh the airbnb situation so
it's going to be a fantastic weekend
according to tourism montreal the
canadian grand prix is the biggest
tourist event in canada attracting more
visitors than both the toronto
international film festival and the
calgary stampede more than a hundred
thousand people have descended on the
city to soak in a sport that's exploded
in popularity since the last race in
2019
you can be the hero today but forgotten
tomorrow the netflix series formula one
drive to survive has been credited with
bringing in a whole new generation of
fans i didn't know anything about f1
before
my boyfriend told me to watch drive to
survive and i got hooked i think it
shows you how much more is behind the
scenes as well it's not just cars going
around in circles yeah it's a very very
chaotic practice lapse qualifying and
the race itself are all sold out and
race organizers are expecting
record-breaking attendance figures one
boy's big williams fan the other one's a
big ferrari fan hope red bull wins and
those attending will be treated to some
canadian content montreal natives lance
stroll and nicholas latifi will be
racing in front of their hometown crowd
a very loud weekend ahead for a city
that was all too quiet for far too long
dan specter global news montreal
and that is global national for this
thursday night i'm faran oster thank you
so much for spending part of your
evening with us
tonight's your canada is lake tamagomi
in ontario until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other good night
[Music]
you